getting through security at mccarran
airport will now be easier with the
latest upgrades in aviation security
technologies
madison kimbrough joining us now live
from there on what you can expect when
you go through tsa checkpoints madison
yes this is the official reopening of
this innovation checkpoint and check it
out as it's pretty cool we can bring
this to you live
right inside of the airport right in
front of it as it offers a lot of new
features for
travelers now it's described as the
first and only one of its kind
in the nation this checkpoint offers
additional security screenings for extra
protection
and precaution but it shouldn't add to a
person's wait time
new digital signs allows for travelers
to easily see what they can
and can't bring through security and
also show security wait times
one of the biggest features credential
authentication technology that's also
known as cat
federal tsa security director for nevada
karen burke says
the system takes away the need for a
boarding pass and all you need is an id
i would tell you the crown jewel of test
sites for tsa
and for the future of aviation security
is right behind me
this is absolutely the most superb and
one-of-a-kind
the only one in the country that has
this kind of technology
and the ability to do testing to be able
to have
a great customer experience as well as a
good
environment for our employees as well
other features include an automated bin
return with a mechanism that uses an
ultraviolet light system
to clean bins plexiglas barriers and new
body scanner which will reduce the
number of pat-downs
now take a look here as these are the
bins that we were talking about now when
you see that the light is green
that means the bin is clean so that
definitely gives me
some peace of mind when i am headed to
the airport putting my items into these
bins
i've always worried about that so this
opening will be open to the public in
this checkpoint
on thursday morning reporting live from
inside of mccarran international airport
madison kimbrough 8 news now madison
thanks in